i have posted several videos on all
things quitting social media and today
i'm excited to bring along a fresh
perspective so i'm going to be
interviewing my close friend b she is a
warm-hearted lover of all things nature
health and fitness and we are going to
be talking about all things
relationships what relationships are
like with versus without social media
how you keep up with friends and what
dating is like as well because
undoubtedly when you first make that
decision to stop social media it can be
a difficult decision and it can feel
isolating or lonely so hopefully you'll
find this information helpful and if you
do like this video please don't forget
to give it a thumbs up and subscribe so
that you won't miss when i post a new
video so without further ado let's get
on with the interview
so b thank you so much for meeting with
us today and talking about this topic i
know that a lot of people
are questioning whether or not they
should quit social media what
relationships are like with or without
social media or even dating and what
that's like so thank you
for meeting with me today and making
this time
and the first thing that i wanted to
talk about is you have had social media
and i remember when we first talked
about how i quit social media you did a
social media fast and you basically went
for a long period of time without social
media and i just wanted to ask first
what made you decide to do that
well first i want to thank you for
inviting me and we've been talking this
for a long time yeah about social media
i don't know because every year i always
do a fasting it's our church fasting
then i always hold off social media for
i think it's like one month passing okay
yeah so i did that you have to give up
everything like instagram tick tock
facebook uh i don't really have all
those things well i don't have those i
only have like i was really hooked with
instagram so um so i decided to uh hold
up so i don't know i felt like
after one month of doing my danielle
fasting i feel great i feel like oh it's
time i'm done with my fasting and i
should be on i should get back in social
media
but for me i mean i was just like
happier not having a social media i
don't think it's necessary for me to be
on again it's not for every everybody
but for me it was time consuming um it's
not like i always post all the time but
i would love to share like posting like
with my hiking my travel i love that
but i feel like it's not i'm comparing
myself with other people but sometimes i
don't have time i always have a very
hectic schedule tight schedule working
long day long hours
so did it make you more stressed
it made me like less stress not having
habits seriously because at the end of
the day like working long day
instead of being with your phone it's
not like you're posting you just look
and then look with the other people what
they do and everything and sometimes you
won't have time for yourself my life my
own life not having your own time and
instead not having a relationship with
god instead like being with social media
instead
yes yes yes that makes a lot of sense
yeah yeah
well one of the things that people are
often worried about when it comes to
quitting social media is
how do you keep up with your friendships
and is it possible to keep up with your
friendships so that's something that i i
would be wonderful to talk about because
we've been friends for a long time and i
haven't had social media so talk about
your perspective on how you maintain
friendships yeah for me
i'm the kind of person that i always
reach out you know i have so many
friends from different states like
california houston that i used to live
in california so i
i don't really need to talk to them
every day but random i just message and
then if i want to share like i went
hiking or stuff like that i just
share it with the people that i love and
you know like my family yeah you know me
so if not i just reach out like hey how
are you how's your day
and some people would ask me that
question they were just wondering hey
what's wrong everything good you're
quiet how come you don't have social
media like yesterday i had dinner with
my friend and then that
and then she said you don't have social
media are you not going to go back to
social media
and then i'm just being it's kind of a
weird thing isn't it like yeah i feel
like like you don't have it what yeah
it's just like you know even at work
everyone does it's uh facebook but i
want to have a private i just
come to the point you're the mysterious
woman yeah i'm the mysterious
the single mysterious woman so um what i
do i just reach out once in a while like
you know happy thursday happy friday you
know and then you kind of like go out
keep up yeah keep up and then but they
respect me with my decision not having
it because it's not like it's gonna end
of the world right right on social media
and i learned it from you
well i'm glad
i mean uh it made me happier no stress
no pressure for me i don't have to be
like in public that i have to show like
what's going on in my life so
i it just comes to the point that i just
want to have my own privacy and then off
social media then i could still keep up
with friends yeah you know i mean so
it's not really a big deal like you
really have to have a social media it's
a time consuming for me and i have a
busy life
yeah i have a busy life and i have you
know like a day after work things to do
i'm more happier i have time to focus on
you now yes exactly that's the right
word yeah do you feel like it also in a
way showed you who your friends really
are like which were the acquaintances
that you mentioned and which were
actually friends that are there for you
that you can actually lean on yeah i
think so because some of them i haven't
heard from them you know i mean it is
what it is but it's not really a big
deal but you wouldn't really know who
your friends yes yes yes i think that's
one of the things that it helps them now
talking about dating and what dating is
like with social media versus without
social media do you think that that
really changes in any significant way
where
let's say social media either improves
or can worsen a relationship what do you
think about that having had it and not
had it for me i think um
not having a social media
because i started january it helps it
really helps me like on me like focusing
on myself my life what's important
uh
what should i do what's the highlight
what's my goal
it's not like
oh what are we gonna
wear what i'm gonna post oh i'm gonna be
with here like what if i don't have an
airplane you know i mean so it's just
like organic natural so i love it it's
it's more about me being like who you
are who is be not not trying too much
hard it's not like
i'm not saying like everyone that who
really likes social media are trying but
it's just like me like being
you're genuine yeah
authentic self yeah that's awesome yeah
so there's no big difference and i i'm
even happier because i did that before
in 2019
uh i was off and then
i think it took me almost two years to
get back on social media so i went for a
time where you didn't have it
and i think you said it was like a month
but then you went back to it and then
you since january till now it's may so
five months that you've gone without it
what was that time like of going back to
it was it like oh what am i really doing
or just just talk about that yeah when i
get back oh yeah so
um although i miss my friends i don't
really see them because you can only see
them because they share pictures in
social media because that's what you do
like tik tok or whatever other like
facebook with their travels and
everything so it's just nice to see them
like when i got back oh you know you
mean but
but it's kind of overwhelming too
because
uh
you know you mean it's like oh i need to
pose you know okay i need to you know
you mean uh it's the pressure like
you tend to compare your life so it kind
of came back
yeah you can you you kind of compare
your life and and i think it's just it's
not helping me to focus on myself so i
just decided to um you know
yes it's just strong to stop and then i
feel better and then i attended a medic
a wedding
like a month ago it's my friend you
shouldn't post it on instagram and then
i was like okay i'm ready to be back in
instagram and then i think i called you
that day that day
i got there in houston and then
okay i need to do uh i need to log in
and instagram okay because i'm gonna be
with my friends and then with my old
friends in houston i'm back and then
here we go attending a nice wedding you
know i'm wearing a nice dress you know i
mean with my friends
i don't know for some reason i try to
am i doing it right
am i doing it do i really have to go
back on instagram
i had a hard time
like i'm having a second thought so
and then never mind never mind forget it
it was like going back to the addiction
ah but you didn't no i didn't so i'm
proud of myself
but i just shared
a few of my friends i think i sent it to
you right uh the wedding yes yes yes see
and that's where i think you can
really
develop a deeper relationship with those
people that you really care about that
really care for you because
you're connecting with them or it's more
of a private thing like oh look i went
to this event or i did this thing where
it's not for the world to see where a
lot of people will just comment or give
a like or a thumbs up and they don't
really care about you they don't care
so yeah that's awesome yeah good for you
i know
so last question where i think we can
just leave off is
what advice would you have to people
that are thinking of quitting social
media or people that are in
relationships
or
trying to date without having social
media because a lot of people i guess
they think they have to have social
media to be able to find people online
it's not really i think it's not really
for all having a social media there's
nothing wrong with having a social media
yeah because you know that i understand
that that's how people connect stay
connect right and then meet people but
those people are social media for my
advice they don't just have to focus
like social media is their life like
right every every minute every second
it's just like during your phone oh at
the post like selfie it's just like it's
not really healthy you know i mean so
you you can't really focus with yourself
so there's nothing wrong as long as it's
just like about balance you know i mean
how to balance your life i love that i
mean so
being positive because sometimes it
could be negative people people have
said that the word balance is toxic like
it's overused but i think it's wonderful
because
i don't think social media is evil it's
not a bad thing like you said it
connects people yeah but at the same
time if you take it to extremes where
we're doing this
yeah or we're talking on our phones and
we're sitting across each other having
dinner but we're not really talking to
each other like yes that happens yeah
because that happens to like oh before
you know
like you know like we eat before we eat
we have to bless the food but now oh
wait wait we're going to take a picture
of the place
i'm so sure like no forget the blessings
let's take a selfie i know right so
something like that so it's about
balance i mean it's not all about social
media you know i mean that's your life
that's your focus so but there's nothing
wrong it's just like not too much you
know i love that as the conclusion like
you own your life work on you improving
yourself
and just finding that happy balance for
you whatever that means
well thank you so much for meeting with
us to talk about this
yes thank you anytime girl
thank you guys for watching and
subscribe and like for more videos like
this